to give you like a bit of background
about me uh as here in the intro I work
for NVIDIA I work on a couple of
different open source kind of groups uh
one is rapids one is dask like my main
focus is about taking like GPU
accelerated data science tools you know
Pi data libraries and running those kind
of anywhere people who want to run those
so whether that's on the cloud whether
that's on NH HBC um using whatever stack
uh people like so there kind of a theme
that'll come up throughout that uh
through this talk but the thing I want
to talk about uh today is kind
of taking taking an application of
scaling out some large computational
problem onto the cloud and kind of
talking about you know something topical
I guess so um I want to talk a bit about
llm data
pre-processing so like it's very common
to uh you know for for llm practitioners
to start with data sets like common craw
or you know the Wikipedia dumps or
archives you know set of papers um and
there's like a whole bunch of
pre-processing that we have to do to
those like these files come in different
formats um they're kind of organized in
different ways there's kind of a lot of
unusable stuff in there there's um lots
of duplicates and things and so one of
the first things we need to do is kind
of download this data get it in the
right format clean it up do the like
data engineering stuff
basically and so like uh a reasonably
common pipeline for doing this uh it
kind of follows this this path and this
is taken from a blog post I'm going to
reference like throughout um I've put it
in the in the like resources tab in
the uh the air me thing so if you want
to go and find the link to these blog
posts uh you can click those in the
resources they'll also be kind of TR out
the slides and again at the end um but
when you're working with these data sets
the first thing you need to do is is
download those data sets somewhere
whether that's into like object storage
on the cloud or on some local cluster um
you need to do all the text extraction
and pull it out into a format that you
want to work with you then need to go
through clean the data um duplicate the
text do quality filtering do all sorts
of other bits and pieces um before you
can actually work with that with that
data and so I kind of want to highlight
this tool that that's being worked on uh
by another group uh adjacent to Rapids
within Nvidia called Nemo um and they're
building lots of Tools around uh natural
language processing and and one of the
things uh that they came up with
recently is this tool called Nemo data
curator so this is a library that will
help you download these data sets clean
them format them duplicate them all of
that kind of stuff um so you can go over
to like the M documentation and learn
learn more about Nemo and what's going
on there um but in this talk I kind of
want to talk about like the P dat stack
that's being used underneath all of this
and the open source libraries that we
work on within Rapids that have been
built together um to solve this to solve
this problem and to just kind of
highlight why um the the group did a
bunch of kind of benchmarking of the
effect of doing data preparation and
data cleaning on kind of the the
accuracy of the the model that's trained
and so one of the things I wanted to
pick out here as you can see one of the
biggest improvements in in Downstream
accuracy here is the duplication of the
data right so going through all of the
different files in these data sets and
trying to remove files that are you know
extremely similar not 100% similar I
mean we definitely want to remove things
that are 100% similar but removing
things that are like 99% the same um we
see a good uplift in in Downstream
performance but actually doing that on
these data sets is is quite a large kind
of Challenge and so we Ed a bunch of
different libraries to kind of build up
this workflow that we need to run so the
first uh kind of set of things that I
want to I want to talk about is is
Rapids now this is this is kind of the
group that I work in within Nvidia um
and you can go and find us on GitHub we
have like a GitHub org it's github.com
Rapids aai and it's got a whole bunch of
kind of Open Source python libraries um
that are GPU accelerated and these kind
of fit into the Pata ecosystem um so if
you're already familiar with librar like
numpy or pandas or psyit learn or
network X or you know kind of the the
Staples of the data science Community um
you'll find within Rapids these kind of
drop-in Replacements that accelerate
those libraries right so if you like
pandas you can go and try CDF if you
like psychic learn you can go and try ql
you like Network X you can try K graph
Etc kind of all of these libraries are
kind of re-engineered from the ground up
um using Cuda and using GPU acceleration
but like the python API that's presented
at the top is kind of the familiar Pi
data libraries that we're we're kind of
all all used to today but we get some
awesome speedups from doing this right
rewriting that low-level code um to kind
of parallelize on gpus we can get some
some awesome um improvements we can see
that like one machine with 16 gpus in um
is more powerful than like a hundred
machines with CPUs in um we can kind of
run through these kind of you know data
Frame data engineering uh operations
with with qdf uh and other libraries so
this is kind of what what Rapids is
focusing on is taking these things that
you would normally do in pandas or numpy
or psychic learn and kind of
accelerating that with gpus kind of
moving the scope of the GPU Beyond model
training you know like we we see GPU
benefits in pie torch and XD boost and
tensor flow and all these things today
but like also accelerating with the
other parts of the the pipeline it's
kind of what we're going after with
Rapids now if you want to like learn any
more about this or if this is
interesting I can highly recommend one
of my colleagues Ashwin is giving a talk
later about this uh new Library released
recently called qdf pandas which is a
plugin for pandas that means that you
can just accelerate your existing pandas
code you don't even have to convert it
over to qdf or do any migration at all
you just import the plugin at the top of
your notebook or the top of your script
um and the the library will kind of
switch out it will opportunistically
switch out pandas where where it thinks
there's some benefit um so you can kind
of get zero code change GPU acceleration
uh for all of your existing pandas
workflows that you already have today so
so go and check out ashman's talk we'll
talk a bit about kind of the performance
games we're seeing but this the kind of
stuff we're seeing with this is taking a
panda's worklad and you know rivaling
kind of the best of breed libraries that
we're seeing coming out today like Duck
DB and polers but without having to
rewrite anything without having to learn
in your new apis you just add a GPU add
this plugin and your Panda's code's
going to go 50 to 130 times faster so
yeah go and check this talk out it's
it's a bit later on today um but all
these libraries are are kind of pretty
popular within the community already we
have lots of existing users lots of
people working on and contributing to
these libraries and seeing this benefit
of of cudar and and GPU acceleration
within their python kind of Pi data
World um so there's there's like a bunch
of material about this already if you
want to learn more about how folks are
using these things go and see you know
some of the talks like this one Spotify
gave a great talk at Nvidia GTC
conference about how they're using uh
the rapid stack to accelerate their
model evaluation but there's like loads
of other talks about this uh like this
um online about how folks are going and
using Rapids so if you want to learn
more about exactly the details of Rapids
then then go and check those
out but once we we start thinking about
okay I want to accelerate my code on my
machine but in order to work through one
of these really big data sets um I'm
going to need lots of machines right I'm
going to need to deploy some kind of
cluster on the cloud I'm going to need
to scale out my workload onto that
cluster um so that I can get through you
know these are like multi-terabyte uh
data sets and you know we're not going
to be able to get through that even on
you know a server full of gpus we're
going to want we're going to want many
machines to work through data sets of
this of this scale so let's talk a
little bit about what it takes to deploy
Rapids on the cloud um and and how we go
about that so one of the core libraries
we use in this stack is a library called
dask if you're familiar with the patri
ecosystem you may have come across this
already um dask is this this kind of
general purpose python library for
parallelizing out your your work um dask
allows you to kind of write custom
parallel code or we have existing
collections that also mimic numpy Panda
psychic learn apis um to to scale out
and so this is this is super useful if
you just have a laptop with with
multiple CPU Calles in and you want to
scale out your work beyond the Gill and
kind of beyond what you can do with
libraries like multiprocessing um
something that feels a bit more kind of
native to to what you're doing but then
you can kind of go beyond that to scale
to to very large clusters and
supercomputers
so the way we the way that we do this
within dask uh is we take a data
structure like a numpy array or a panda
data frame and we we have like a dask
equivalent of that so we have like a
dask array or a Das data frame and these
are kind of chunked partitioned um
flavors of those those apis so if you
look at like a dask data frame is made
up of many partitions and each of those
partitions is a pandas data frame and so
we can kind of swap chunks in and out of
memory we can do out of core processing
and we can distribute this work um out
onto the you know a cluster of some kind
um and because we're talking about uh
pandas and because you've got libraries
like qdf and cf. pandas that are these
like Drop in replacements for pandas we
can bring in these this GPU acceleration
into dask so we can get this kind of
scaleout nature of dask where we break
up our workload um and run it on many
cores or many machines uh we can then
add the GPU acceleration to that as well
so that we can then break up our
workload and run it across many gpus use
in many machines on on like a large GPU
cluster and the way that we do this
within dask uh is we have these kind of
high level apis that mimic these these
kind of Pi data apis they break up um
the data structures into chunks they
also kind of have these these parallel
algorithms that replace you know pandas
do you know numpy do mean or something
like we have like a map reduced Style
mean operation within dask that will
give you the same result um but because
we've broken this out into a task graph
we can have all these individual tasks
assigned to different different cores or
different gpus um and we we have like a
a distributed scheduler within dask
which uh allows you to you run the
scheduler you run a bunch of workers on
a bunch of machines um and then you
connect a client in your your notebook
or in your python script um these are
all kind of things you could just import
and instantiate and they'll all connect
together and then when you run your code
it will kind of generate this task graph
pass the task graph to the scheduler
scheduler will distribute of these tasks
onto the workers and they'll start
chugging through it very very quickly um
and some of the things that people
really love about dask is that we try
and visualize and represent what's going
on to you so if you have this large you
know chunked array kind of in your
notebook you can see okay this is the
shape and size and dimensionality of my
array this is the size of it this is how
big each chunk is and this you know as
I'm going to run an operation like mean
um this is how my the shape of my
computation is going to look and then we
have a dashboard that shows like what
are the work is doing what tasks are
being run at the moment what's taking
the time um because sometimes when you
run these workloads if they take a very
long time it's nice to be able to go in
and get an insight into into what's
going on uh within your within your
cluster so being able to mix Rapids and
dask together means that we have to
think about how do we deploy kind of GPU
clusters on the cloud with dask running
so that we can come and use this um as
you know as an end user how do I
actually get all of this so we put a lot
of effort over the last year in Rapids
into this into a a Rapids deployment
documentation website the links here is
doc. rapids. a deployment um and then
there's kind of loads of different pages
in here that talk about here's how to
set up a GPU dask cluster on Sage maker
here's how to set it up on vertex AI
here's how to set it up on Z zero Mal or
if you want to use kubernetes to kind of
abstract away the the platform
underneath you can use kubernetes um
there's also kind of lots of managed
Services out there like coil or datab
Brees that you can go and kind of run
these things on as well and so this
documentation will walk through how do I
install the libraries how do I start the
dask cluster how do I get the Jupiter
environment how do I kind of get going
with all of this and then we have a load
of like endtoend workflow examples of
you know kind of showing given some
selection of these tools right
everybody's got a different stack right
every organization has made a choice
about who they're going to buy from and
uh which Cloud they're going to use and
which Services they like um but as long
as you can get a GPU there we want to be
a to use Rapid there so we have these
kind of workflow examples that okay I've
Got Dat S3 I want to use sagemaker I
want to scale out with eks I want you
know whatever your opinion to stack is
and then we have some example notebooks
that's like here's how to deploy that
and then do high parameter optimization
or here's how to deploy that and then do
um some data pre-processing so if you're
interested in any of this go go and
check out that
documentation now in order to run this
kind of large D duplication workload
that we want to do uh for this
pre-training these these llms we we can
you know choose kubernetes maybe as as
one one approach to this saying okay I
want some gpus to run through this work
I'm going to deploy them on some Cloud
by creating a kubernetes cluster I'm
then going to install dask we have a we
have a dask operator kind of plug in for
kubernetes which lets you create Das
clusters uh nicely on kubernetes and
then we're going to use Rapids the
Rapids libraries on top of that so just
to kind of illustrate we can do this
quite quickly say I'm going to choose
Google Cloud for for my kubernetes class
um I can run like one command that will
create a kubernetes cluster with some
gpus or the other clouds have kind of
got a rough equipment of this um I'm
then going to go and install kind of the
the Nvidia plugins for this so that the
kubernetes cluster is aware of the
gpus I can then come in and install the
dask operator which makes the kubernetes
cluster aware of with dask as a as a
concept and kind of be able to create
dask
clusters and then we can kind of list
our dask clusters uh and create them so
like we have one like a nice little one
liner for for deploying Rapids onto this
um using the D kubernetes gen cluster
command line tool which kind of
generates all the specs for you and
everything but you can say Okay I want
to use the Rapids Docker container that
we publish which has got all of these
libraries and Jupiter and everything
else you could want in it I'm going to
deploy that as a cluster um I'm going to
ask for each you know the notebook the
scheduler and each worker in my cluster
to have one GPU um and that you know I
specify I want Das Das jupyter I want
this to have Jupiter so this is my front
end and I can come in I don't need to
have a GPU in my you know I can work on
a MacBook I don't need a GPU I can run
this on the cloud um and kind of work in
in Jupiter in this environment and this
is a great way for us to do this this
kind of pre-processing work um scaled
out on the cloud we can turn on all the
autoscaling and all those kind of
features if we want so that when we're
working in our notebook we're just
taking up a small amount of resource and
then when we run our run our
pre-processing job it will kind of scale
out ad nodes and we're only build for
what we need in that in that time but
like that's just that's one approach
that we could take to deploying Rapids
and and kind of getting these tools in
our hands um we kind we have
documentation on that site for all sorts
of different platforms kind of every
service you could think of in the
different Cloud providers um and if
you're interested in this stuff and you
don't see your preferred provider here
go and open an issue on the repo um and
kind of say and we can we can go and
fill in uh another documentation page
there
so once we're at this point right and
we've deployed our Rapids dask cluster
onto our you know kubernetes in this
example but once we've deployed this
somewhere um how do we actually go
through this workload how do we
duplicate these these large data sets um
so one of the first things we want to do
is just kind of think about this
operation we need to take every document
in a data set like a Wikipedia dump and
we need to compare that document to
every other document within that data
set because we want to see how similar
they are and then discard any duplicates
but that is you know that's an all toall
operation that's a big operation if
we've got an extremely large
multi-terabyte data set made up of
trillions of tiny files doing an all
toall comparison is really big thing to
do so one of the first things we can do
is is try and group our documents
together using some some hashing um you
know locality sensitive hashing so that
we're going to generate like a short
like a 32 byte hash for each file and
files that are kind of similar in
structure and and everything will get a
similar hash and because we're working
with so many files we could just
generate a hash for each file and then
we'll get lots and lots of files that
end up with the same hash and we can
kind of use that to bucket our files and
say okay we're going to duplicate we're
going to first kind of Bin them into
these buckets using using uh like Minash
and then we're going to then only do the
duplication within those buckets so
there like this first cut allows us to
come in and kind of reduce our problem a
little bit because this is still a
gigantic problem um so the the next
thing we're going to need to do once
we've got these buckets of files um
we're going to need to come up with our
all of the comparisons we want to do so
we'll go through every file within each
bucket and kind of put together a data
frame of pairs right I've got file X and
file Y in bucket Z they need to be
compared to each other and compared to
the other file in in bucket Z and next
file next file whatever so we end up
generating this this big data frame that
just shows all of the pairs right all of
the buckets all of the pairs um but we
can do this with uh dask so that we end
up with this very large data frame that
kind of describes our problem right
describes all the different comparisons
we want to make um but we don't have to
hold that data frame in memory on a
single machine even if this data set is
is many terabytes you know the metadata
of this data set is already huge just
describing all of these files their file
names and their buckets and everything
so we can create that as this big dask
data frame um and we can just kind of
Chunk our way through
that uh and we can load that up and
actually join that with the text in the
original data set and all of this in
dask is is lazy so we end up with this
this kind of nice data frame where we
have kind of the text of a document and
a text of another document in a row and
we just have many many rows and these
all just show all of the comparisons
that we want to do right in order to to
R see whether or not this is the same
the same document um but this is at this
point like a many terabyte data frame
representing all of the data um we've
kind of exploded it out and and have
lots of duplication in there because
you're comparing all the files with all
the other files but because all of this
is lazy and because all of this is is
done in dask we don't have to worry
about actually fitting that into memory
we just choose our chunk size to be
something that will fit in memory we can
have as many chunks as we want to work
through work through this data set and
then we can actually kind of map over do
a rowwise operation over this data frame
and do this comparison so uh the way the
the the the Nemo team has done this in
data curator is is by calculating the
jackard similarity for each file um I
would highly recommend going and and
reading the documentation and having a
look at a a demo YouTube video uh that
someone from the the ql team gave about
how to actually do this um but these are
using kind of standard pandas operations
in order to do this
um do this computation so if you imagine
we're looking at one row and we just
want to compare the text of one document
with the text of another document first
thing we need to do is explode each
document out into engrams right you can
see this representation on the left
we're just going to take kind of this is
like a showing like a five gram right we
take five characters in like a rolling
window over the document we're going to
kind of explode out into into that and
then we can compare um the two documents
to see what the overlap is right to see
um what common engrams they have between
them so we can use the Panda's explode
operation um but because we've loaded
this with Das qdf is still the same
pandas API that we we know and love um
but it's now like a chunked distributed
accelerated variation of that same that
same
operation um we can then on each row you
know use kind of standard pandas
operations like join and group by and
and divide to compare
these engrams with each other add them
up and work out what the jackard
similarity is for each one and this
would give us a number between zero and
one to show us how similar each row is
Right each document comparison um and
then we can make some kind of decision
about uh you know what's our threshold
with for for discarding duplicates what
do we consider a duplicate and where do
we kind of make the cut to throw things
away and we can see by running this on
many machines using dask um to scale
this out and then using qdf uh and gpus
to to accelerate this computation we can
like look at an example like the the 4
and a half terabyte red pajama data set
um running this through on like a CPU
cluster with 20 nodes you know and each
node has got like a decent CPU with many
many cores running this through took 37
hours whereas just on four nodes with
some gpus in this cut all the way down
to three hours right so this allows us
to kind of do this pre-processing ingest
new data train new models more quickly
update these models more more easily um
by using gpus to kind of accelerate some
of this this
pre-processing and it also uh you know
can provide like a cost saving as well
because you imagine 20 nodes 20 high-end
nodes rented on the cloud running for 37
hours is going to cost more than four
GPU nodes even though the GPU nodes cost
more um per hour you're not going to
need anywhere near as many of them and
you're not going to need them for
anywhere near as long so by switching to
GPU acceleration um we're still kind of
just working in our standard pandas way
right but we're kind of switching around
from CPU to many CPU to many GPU to kind
of cut down time and cut down cost of of
running through
this so uh that's kind of the end of of
what I wanted to show today to leave you
with these these links um we have this
this blog post that the team uh the Nemo
team's written up about data curator and
how it works and what it does um and all
the other pieces that pipeline right
we've just focused in this talk on um
just doing fuzzy D duplication of the
documents but there's so many other
stages of actually getting the data
doing all the Transformations other
cleaning um other quality control uh and
and things so go and read the the new
documentation um it's really interesting
to see kind of how they've done that and
they link all the papers and things in
there and then also if you want to learn
more specifically about the how we
calculate the the jard similarity then
go and have a look at the Das demoday
session from from earlier this year um
where showed that and again if you want
to learn more about CF and CF pandas go
along to ashman's talk later on today
but that's it uh thank you very much for
your time we got five minutes left so if
anybody has any questions uh please go
ahead and put them in the
chat thanks Jacob there's the first
question from
Ian uh it should be showing up on the
screen now yeah I can see I'll read them
out and then ask them so uh yeah
regarding KF pan what sort of memory
limits are we subject to does the data
frame have to fit into the gpu's vram am
I limited to 10 gab data frames when I
might have a 64 GB system yeah
absolutely so in that case when we're
just talking about you know we're not
worrying about dask we're just talking
about accelerating pandas on a single
machine um then yeah CF pandas will be
limited by the the memory of the GPU um
if you want to add dask to the mix it
can then swap data in and out and do
kind of outof course stuff so you're not
you're never actually Bound by that
limitation but yeah if you have 64 gig
of ram in a machine and a GPU you know W
with only 10 gig of RAM you'll be
limited by that but the the nice thing
about qdf pandas is it will try and
accelerate things and if it reaches the
memory limit and blows up it'll just say
Okay this isn't a GPU operation it gets
too big I can switch back to normal
pandas so um to you the user you won't
notice any difference it's just that KF
pandas will speed things up where it can
speed things up um and it's got a really
nice little profiler in there it will
show you like line by line in your code
where oh it managed to run this on the
GPU or this fell back to to CPU but yeah
go along to to ashen's talk and and and
have a look if you want to learn more
about that
one uh so the next question was how
reliable was your jackard document pair
comparison measured to say cosign did
you for jackard metric for better
performance so I honestly can't um speak
to this this was something that was done
by the Nemo team I'm just kind of like
showing an example that we've run at
scale with Rapids and Das um I would
highly recommend you go and have a look
at their their documentation um and read
they kind of reference a bunch of papers
about you know what they measured and
and why they chose different approaches
so that that would be the place to go
and answer that question